I'm gonna say some stuff that's going to
bother some people people who are
listening to this and are not making as
much money as they want they have to Mr
Alex from Ozzy 100 million dollar man
entrepreneur investor and philanthropist
taking the Internet by storm this guy
really really does understand how to
build a business I was 22. I had done
everything that my dad had wanted me to
do and I was looking out from the condo
that I had been able to buy with this
job that I had and um I always hoped I
wouldn't wake up the next day I cherish
the fact that it was so miserable that
it got me to change pain motivates
significantly faster and stronger than
pleasure does if you are angry use it if
you are sad use it or it uses you I
didn't know whether I would succeed but
I did know I wasn't going to stop right
around that point is when I met my wife
and then she just changed my life how
did she change it like
[Music]
didn't think we're gonna go here
um
she just She Believes In Me
she stood tall when everything in my
life was crumbling around me I was like
dead broke in her parents house and I
was like I I think you should leave me
she pulled my chin towards her and she
was like
I would sleep with you under a bridge if
it came to that
six months later I have three million
dollars in the bank account all of that
was the first nine months of our
relationship
for her to have that kind of belief was
was vario
it was deep for me
and I think that's what most guys want
truly
what makes a really good entrepreneur
slash leader I'll answer this
differently than I have in the past and
I'm going to tell a story that hopefully
people don't take the wrong way but I
had a cat
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
I spend several hours consuming all of
your content across multiple channels
what is the AIM
what is the mission what is the the
intent
if you were to try and summarize the
content you're producing and the value
you're trying to add and to who are you
trying to add it to
make business accessible for everyone
that was the mission of the company and
so our whole idea was
we'll put everything out there uh for
free so no pay walls so there's like we
have courses on the side the books I
have for 99 cents
um so that anyone can get them and you
know we'll continue to produce as much
as we can and we
share the learnings that we have from
our portfolio companies
in order to keep the stuff that we are
putting out there relevant new fresh
Cutting Edge because this is what's
working today
and by doing that it also brings other
companies to us because they get value
from the stuff and our goal is always to
hopefully provide more value to a
company before they've ever spoken to us
like kind of pay for ourselves in
advance is kind of like the thought
process even though we're buying in
um and that's that was kind of the
thesis when we started it I didn't know
if it was going to work
but it seems to have gone pretty well uh
and it was just kind of just like if we
just give and keep giving and keep
giving we just focus on the value and
delivering to the audience
um it'll come back eventually what are
you giving them and who are you giving
it to
entrepreneurs at all stages we've
surveyed the audience 25 of the audience
has a business 75 does not have a
business but wants to start a business
and so that's just kind of overall
um and then within that 25 it just kind
of categories all the way up to you know
businesses doing 100 million plus a year
and so it's everyone and so we try and
are one of the things that we talk about
is like going wide and deep it's like
how can we figure something that is
relevant to somebody who's you know
launching their first product and also
make it accessible or interesting to
somebody who's launching a new product
line within a division of their
conglomerate right and just trying to
think about both people at the same time
which becomes more challenging but it's
also kind of fun
kind of like a funnel isn't it in some
respects um that's exactly what I saw
from your content Europe you're making
great content that's helping people that
are at the start of their Journey
or you know 100 employees deep into
their Journey trying to figure out how
to scale you're making content that's
bringing down some of the barriers where
the psychological or practical to enable
them to reach whatever dream they have
let's go way Upstream then
what do I need to know about you to
understand the life you've LED take me
way back to your childhood in the early
context
both parents are immigrants to the U.S
uh mother was born in France came here
but father was born in Iran they met in
medical school in Europe and then my
mother brought him back with her to the
US and then uh
they had me and they split my mom had a
lot of demons she had a lot of things
she struggled with when I was coming up
so I pretty much was raised by my dad I
had no siblings it was just me and my
dad for
until I was about 15.
um he got remarried it was a short stint
in terms of how long I was like kind of
in the house you know like right at that
stage is when you can drive and I was
kind of on my own almost at that point
as soon as I could work and drive I was
kind of out of the house and then from
there
did the thing that most people try and
do which is uh I I worked hard at school
mostly because I just didn't want my dad
to be upset with me which was uh the
main driver for most of my achievement
in my career
for the first half was all just trying
to gain his approval
did all the things that I thought he
would want me to uh
got a job at a Government Contracting
consulting firm uh defense Contracting
it was space cyber and ISR so it's
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance for the military sounded
really cool
was less cool when you were in it and I
was very very sad at that point in my
life and so it was very much like I
didn't I always hoped I wouldn't wake up
the next day
um
truly you really mean that a hundred
percent
100 because I remember when I was
looking at
um because a lot of people have like
rock top moments sorry Rock Bottom
moments I think I had more of a rock top
moment which was
um
I was 22.
I had done everything that my dad had
wanted me to do at this point I was
looking out from the condo that I had
been able to buy with this job that I
had and um I was like is this it
in the whole time I just really didn't
enjoy my life
um and it was just you know
not wanting to wake up
and it was
the the decision to
leave Baltimore which is where I was
from
to quit that path to decide to start a
business of my own
was still to this day the hardest thing
I've ever done by far all the things
we've been through to build what we have
the hardest decision was taking the leap
for me and it was because like I knew
that my dad
so much wanted me to do what I was doing
because he was so happy that I was doing
everything he wanted me to do at that
point and I had told him over and over
again that I wanted to do this other
stuff and he's like yeah yeah like later
you know later
um and so I knew that it would probably
put a big dent in our relationship if I
left but for me it was actually
confronting the fact that I didn't want
to be alive anymore which was the thing
that gave me enough courage or whatever
you want to call it to actually make the
decision to leave home and so I started
driving across the country I mean it
took me six months to do this like when
I between when I decided I really wanted
to do this and when I actually did it
took me six months
and I called him when I was like halfway
across the United States and I was like
I'm going to California I'm gonna open a
gym I'm gonna get into fitness and he
was like why are you so extreme and you
like lost it and then we didn't really
talk much for a long time
when you started
realizing that your life
um was one where you didn't want to wake
up in the morning when you had that job
in management consultancy did you
experience suicidal ideation is that
what you were saying when you say I
don't I didn't want to wake up into my
life every day it was never like I've
never had a like this is how I'd kill
myself nope never had that I just always
like the idea that I could not wake up
the next day sounded good
when you look back in hindsight from
that moment backwards what are the
series of decisions or the the things
that led you to find yourself in the
position and I asked that because
there's a lot of people that can
probably relate
and and there's probably quite a
consistent
set of frog pads or stones that one has
walking down for whatever reason that
leads you to a position where you go
what the [__] whose life is this
I think they're like the one line
summary for me was that like I felt like
I had to let my dad's dream die from
mine to live
and I felt like my entire life it had
always up to that point had been like
go to the school do these studies I mean
it's it's a common thing like it's not
like I had something that a lot of
people don't have many people and to be
fair I'm very grateful for the skills
discipline Etc that that instilled in me
um because I think you you you have the
the hard hand of an authoritarian parent
when you're growing up and it teaches
you a lot of skills and then you know
the flip side is if you have a very less
Affair parent like you never learn those
skills which then benefit you later so
you know who knows
um but for me uh
I knew that he just wanted me to be a
doctor that's what he was that would
have been his dream I went to school as
pre-med
um and then I I it was like even
changing my degree from pre-med to just
a business degree was like a huge deal
um
but he was okay with that as long as I
followed like the business path and so
when I did my two years of consulting
which is kind of the typical like two to
four years you do Consulting and then
you apply to go to Business School
um
when I was going through that process I
was answering the question for like the
Harvard MBA and it was like how will
Harvard MBA help your short and
long-term goals
and I sat there for like two days trying
to answer the question and I was like it
just isn't I want to start a business
and so that was when I kept trying to
you know start that conversation with my
dad and it just wasn't really happening
um and so that's what that was kind of
the breaking point for me was like I
just felt terrible about my life and I
didn't didn't like the way it was going
and
I
for me it was such a key point because
the biggest line of reasoning I had for
myself in order to convince myself to
confront my father or at least
disappoint my father or the version of
myself that he wanted me to be was to
say that like I have to be comfortable
dying in his eyes
and a lot of people like
and many people might think that was
hyperbole but for me it was very true
like I I knew that I would die in his
eyes and I did
um to give you context
so I had the gyms and I opened up
multiple after that got to about six
locations sold those started a gym
turnaround business did that for two
years
um
all the while we weren't really in you
know we were like okay in touch
um and then we started the licensing
business which is gym launch and that's
the one that like really took off
and we hadn't been super in touch and I
got a call out of the blue and he wasn't
like a cold call you know I mean I was
like this is weird so I pick up the
phone and he's like you're going to want
to sit down for this and I was like
okay uh what's up I was thinking like
cancer you know I mean I'm just like
what what is it going to be he's like
I'm sorry and I was like
for what he was like you know
everything I was like okay
and I was very angry though because I
mean this is what I told him so I was
like I was like you know that point when
people like get on stage and they accept
the awards and mind you at this point I
think we're doing we're probably taking
home
one and a half million a month you know
what I mean and take home like personal
income from the license it was a decent
sign like is it I'm not you know
conglomerate like probably what is
decent sized business
and I was like you know
when people get on stage and they accept
awards for things I was like the first
thing they always say is like hey I just
think my mom and dad for always
believing in me and I was like I'm not
gonna say that I was like because you
did it
I was like you're only saying this now
once everyone believed because it's not
belief anymore it's fact it's evidence I
was like so you're I was like this
apology means nothing to me
and
besides that I stopped caring what you
thought six years ago which is why I
left
and so I had like that's like I I could
have just accepted it and I I didn't do
that
um how did you feel about that
I probably like today I probably would
have said thanks I appreciate it I know
where he was trying I he was trying to
extend an olive branch
um and I just wasn't there I was still
seething I was still very angry that I
had not gotten any support during that
process and maybe that was very woe as
me
um but I was still very angry at that
point
and you know to give also a little bit
of context you know his response to that
was like
well we'll see how long it lasts you're
joking no so like my father not like
he is a very strong personality and so
do I and we both think we're right are
you angry about it now
honestly no I mean like
I think I can still feel the emotions
but
I feel like I've you know thought about
it enough to say that I can logically
say I think he absolutely did the best
he could with what he had he's a single
dad
another country
raising a kid trying to get that kid to
fit in and do the things that like one
of the things that I think my dad always
wanted me to be able to do is like
because he's darker skin than I am he's
a middle eastern
um he always wanted me to like have
access to like
the back rooms were like deals were made
that he felt like he wasn't a part of
and so
he just wanted me to have that
and so I think he just drove me as much
as he could to to get that it's just
like when you're on the other side of it
like all you feel is never succeeding
but I can appreciate it now in
retrospect
um but it definitely was still it
hardened me
a lot
but that hardness I think has benefited
me a lot in business
I had someone in the podcast say a quote
which I've never managed to forget they
said you've got to realize that
everybody you encounter everybody that
does you wrong if you were them and you
had been through what they've been
through and you had their brain you'd be
doing the exact same thing yeah and it
sounds it's obvious on one hand but it's
also very kind of Illuminating that
think about the person that's wrong you
the most if you've been through their
shoes and you had their genetics you'd
be doing the exact same thing
doesn't mean you have to let them off
but at least it invokes some empathy
have you heard um you cannot both hate
and understand someone at the same time
true
like if you truly understand someone
then you can't hate them because you
understand why like a lot of times I
hate us from the unknown and not like
because you hates because I mean you
almost say you're like how could like
it's it's literally a statement of not
understanding
um like how could you
if you understood then you would know
how and that resentment is a byproduct
of just not understanding as well I'm
just thinking about resentment that I've
had in my life when I think someone's
wrong me that sense of Injustice you're
right how could yeah
how dare you
did you ever manage to get your fuel to
burn less dirty are you burning less
dirty now yeah I think so you think so
yeah I think so I might my team tells me
um that that's true and if you look at
like because I do have some older videos
that I made from like you know years ago
um and there's definitely a different
vibe
I'm I'm significantly friendlier
than I was then
um I mean even the way I interacted with
customers and you know the team was like
purely fear-driven like I was absolutely
because I didn't understand influence as
well yet
um so only only the stick I had was like
if I if people are afraid of me then
they will immediately comply and it's
effective for short durations but not
for long durations
um and but I didn't know any better at
the time and then I slowed yeah that's
when I you know right around that point
is when I met my wife and then she just
you know changed my life
um and she started running all the
businesses and I'd see her and everyone
left her and I was like man
do more more of that stuff and less of
my stuff she changed her life oh yeah
for sure
or not
I mean she's like
the best
how did she change you
she has brought out the absolute best in
me
like in in just about every way like
didn't think we're gonna go here
um
she just She Believes In Me
and I think that's what most guys want
truly
at least for me that's what I want
or needed
I'll tell you a story to illustrate it
so
we met
talk for four hours on the first date
only about business
because that's all I wanted to talk
about and I pitched your own working for
me I was like quit your job work for me
and she was like I just met you
logically makes sense she was a personal
trainer I had a bunch of gyms and I was
like if you're this good you should
totally work for me
she's like well let's you know let's see
how this goes
um and so I had this idea for the
turnaround business and it was right as
I had five five locations at that point
and I wanted to try this thing out so I
flew out did three turnarounds flew back
and they started working and then
um I sold all my gems because it was
like okay this this makes even more
money I took all the money and put it
into uh this gym that one of the guys I
was doing a turnaround with was like
dude you just crushed this like I'm a
really good operator instead of turning
his gyms around and walking away with
just the money he's like you should just
keep owning them and I'll just fill up
fill them up behind you so I could I
could launch one two three gyms a month
and then own them all he's like you're
leaving so much money on the table it's
like okay so we did this first launch I
put all the money in he's like of course
he had financial difficulties and I had
to personally get the you know
personally guarantee the least normal
stuff
um and so I crushed this launch and then
I wake up one morning and check the bank
account and uh it's completely empty and
I was like
what's happening so I called him up and
he was like well I know you're you're
skimming from the business and it was
like
what he's like I know you're I know
you're you're skipping me I was like I'm
I'm we just what no
um he's like well that was my half uh
and so I was like what is happening so I
printed all the bank the bank statements
I went line by line I was like let me
I'll I'll walk you through all the bank
statements let's just let's get to the
bottom of this and remember we sat in
the meeting and he was like I need to
see that he push it off the table and I
was like oh okay I immediately was like
oh he I just got [__] and he'd already
been indicted for fraud
um and I knew this getting into business
with him and it was just a big
misunderstanding
and you know the saying goes like uh
when experience meets money money gets
the experience and Spirits gets money um
very much lived that and so after I had
all my gyms I sold them put all the
money in this thing and then they all
got taken
um and so I had nothing and um Layla's
with me at this point for this like this
exciting period
so I was like okay she's like hey you
know maybe we should keep doing these
turnarounds instead of this weird launch
and go thing you side sidelined for I
was like okay we'll do that and so I was
going to launch a gym the next month
um and there was a guy who's local to
that gym and since I was refocusing I
was like all right I'm gonna build all
the infrastructure I'll send the sales
guy up to do this thing and uh he
crushed the launch did like 120 000
which for us was a big launch
um in like three days in three weeks
and so now I'm at Layla's parents house
because uh like we don't really have a
house at this point
um and I'm the guy that she met from the
internet that you quit her job for uh
who just lost everything and uh I was I
needed this 100 Grand to come in from
this launch so that I could recapitalize
and
the money wasn't hitting I was checking
the bank account I was like where's this
money like I could see the processing
the transactions and it was all
successful what's going on so I called
the processor up and I was like what's
up and they uh
they said it's a routine check I was
like I told you guys six years it's
never been a routine checking they were
like call again later and I was like
okay so I call about the next day next
day nothing and then finally it was
Christmas Eve
and I owed this guy money for the
commissions from the sales
and I was like I will not get off this
phone until you send me the money that I
mowed and uh to the payment process and
they were like
long story short uh you were doing stuff
in different locations and I was running
this all through a local gym business
even though I was all over the nation
and they were like this is a little
irregular we're just going to hold on to
this for six months [__]
right now I owe the guy twenty two
thousand dollars in commissions I in
total now had twenty three thousand
dollars
so I wired him the money and I had a
thousand dollars left and it was
December of 2016.
and I was like I screenshot it because I
still have the screenshot on my bank
account so I went from like six gyms
turn around business all the stuff to
one thousand dollars I was like this
sucks
and Layla had just got six of her
friends to quit their job to come do
this turnaround business with me and
they were starting two days later from
the 24th so the 26th of December because
I plan on getting this 100 Grand in and
then being able to launch six gyms
because they took about you know
whatever uh it was 3 300 a day in cost
to have six guys out there in the field
selling
3300 a day that I did not have
and so I saw a credit card that hundred
thousand dollar limit on it
um and so I'm at her parents house like
in in an extra bedroom
I haven't lost everything and my one
Hail Mary play of this launch the money
did not come through
and I was like I I think you should
leave me
um I I think I'm a a sinking ship right
now and
I would respect you like we're cool if
you want to walk away
like
we're good like I won't think less of
you like I would walk away from you
right now because this could this has a
very high likelihood of not going right
and um
she pulled my chin towards her and she
was like
I would sleep with you under a bridge if
it came to that
and it's hard to comprehend but like I
had nothing you know like for her to
have that kind of belief was was vario
it was deep for me
so it was like [__] it let's go you know
I mean and so then we we launched the
gyms doing 3 300 a day and uh mind you I
had no way to process money still so I'm
collecting 60 to 80 contracts a day that
I can't process and so we're getting
calls from customers like hey why
haven't you run my car why haven't you
run my card I'm calling all these
processors to be like hey can you please
as soon as you get shut down from a
processor it's like a black mark it's
like going bankrupt for credit cards
um they're like oh no something's weird
we they just won't if other people they
can process the money for
finally I get like a higher risk
processor that does like porn and
casinos and stuff to like give me and
they were like yeah so it's gonna be
like eight percent processing and we're
gonna hold ten percent as like Safeguard
and I was like Jesus okay yes and
they're like and we can only give you
fifty thousand dollars is your limit and
I was like I was like I need like 200.
he's like well and I got this on the
29th of January so this whole time 3300
today is running on this card and I have
no money and I have no way to process it
and 29th of January I can run 50 Grand I
run 50 Grand in a day and he's like but
it's by month he's like so February 1st
you can run another 50. so February 1st
I run another 50. that hundred covers my
cost from the month before and then I
get two more processors for 50. boom
boom run those and then like I got a
third one or fourth one like two weeks
later and I was able to like start
moving things around
um and at the end of February uh we had
made like a thirty thousand dollar
profit and um I was like okay I think we
might be out of this the next month we
did a little bit more and I was like
okay I think this is working and then
all of a sudden Layla tashed me on the
shoulder road morning and she's like she
like turns her laptop towards me and
it's our bank account and has all these
negative transactions like hundreds of
them and I was like what's going on
she's like well all these clients are
calling me saying that the gym that we
did this launch at a month and a half
ago the guy got in his chair and was
like hey
there's too many of you here like just
go home just refund because I was the
one who held the money they had to do
the delivery that was the model it's
like I would fill a gym up I would sell
I'd keep the money
and then they deliver on the services
and after that they could keep the
customers that was kind of like the
setup
and then another gym the next week said
hey this guy made 100 grand out of my
gym the average gym owner makes 36 000 a
year take home he's like this kid from
the internet took 100 grand out in a
month screw that kid and so he told all
the customers who were there after we
had left hey I'll keep believing your
thing refund him just pay me half what
you paid him
out right it was a flawed model like I
didn't understand like I didn't get it
at that point and so we had 150 000 in
refunds that I had to hover and I had no
way of doing it why do you like Layla's
like we're gonna do this I believe in
you and so I'm like I'm like I can't
sleep I remember because what would
happen is like the more we sold the more
the refund like it was a vicious cycle
so I had to sell more to cover the
refunds from the ones that were coming
in and so our sales were going up and it
was just like I just I couldn't breathe
and I was just I would wake up at night
anyways and so I'm like writing on these
ideas of like what I think I could do
we had eight launches that were supposed
to launch next month so I said hey Layla
you have this little weight loss
business because she had her personal
training business she converted her on
her in-person class online during this
whole process so she was making like
three or four thousand dollars a month
and mostly because like I'm not stable
I'm like making all this big money and
losing it all and making it and losing
and she's just like paying groceries and
actually like making sure that I can eat
and I was like tell me more about that I
was like what's your overhead how much
time does it take you and then blah blah
I was like
we're gonna we're gonna do your thing
we're gonna we're gonna call it Queen
transformation I'm gonna start running
ads for it and we're gonna take the
sales team and we're gonna put it on
your thing
and So within 14 days she starts taking
the phone calls because she was a good
salesman um she's doing a thousand bucks
a day online no no all margin what's a
product it was at 16 week like weight
loss program online yeah online exactly
and so it was 500 bucks she was selling
two of them a day and so I was like man
if we get to eight guys going we'll have
eight thousand a day 240 after ad spend
I was like I can make 150 in profit and
like we'll be in the clear so I called
the eight guys that were supposed to
launch the next month the the gyms
so I get on the phone with the first guy
and I was like Hey we're going another
Direction you know we're gonna we're
gonna be a weight loss Company still
direct to consumer
and he was like dude you launched my
buddy's Gym like two months ago and like
he he can't stop talking about you it's
like it's packed
um because there are other gyms that
everything went fine with just the ones
that didn't is the ones that crushed the
business
he's like I know you can do it um and I
just refinanced my house and I maxed out
my credit cards to to make this gym
happen and I I'm gonna lose it
and given what I had been through up to
this point I was like that's tough man
like
um sorry about that and then finally he
was like can you okay instead of flying
can you just show me what you did to
help my buddy out can you just give me
like the system
and since I was like I'm gonna get out
of this gym business I was okay like
selling my secrets and so I was like all
right man I'll I'll give you everything
I have but I'm not gonna fly out there
to save your ass if you can't sell he
said no no it's fine and so I picked up
the highest number I could think of
because he already told me he was broke
so I figured I could just get him off
the phone so we could move on and I said
six thousand dollars and he was like six
grand I was like yeah he was like oh
done
I remember like looking at the phone and
being like
holy [__] six thousand dollars
and I was like oh what card do you want
to use for that wrote like a cardboard
box and then the next call had the same
thing and I was like well shoot I have
to make this thing now and I was like
same conversation he's like how much I
was like eight grand and he was like
yeah okay
and I each of the calls I was like next
call same thing 10 grand next call same
thing 12 Grand and then the next you
know the end of the day I sold 60 000 in
in licensing packages for all of the
stuff that we did to do the turnarounds
is that monthly or is that just
I didn't even have any I was just like
I'm just giving you everything I do yeah
it it became more comfortable like more
uh it became a recurring model over time
but it was a PDF
it was actually on my internal stuff so
it was like what I used to train my
sales teams that would fly out and like
what I would use to train them on how to
do the nutritional orientation like it
was all the internal stuff the only
thing I actually made external was I had
to create the uh the advertising
material so I had to basically make a
white label landing page for the gyms
that they could put their logo on and
then I gave I license them the ads
themselves that we already knew to
convert it right so like the videos the
copy everything they used like videos of
me that we knew converted and I taught
them how to run them and then that's
that's what it did it and uh we made
sixty thousand dollars in a day and I
like Layla came in from doing her 2
sales for weight loss and I was like
I think we're still in the gym business
and she was like what I thought we were
doing weight loss like you just told me
you sold me on weight loss being like
the next thing
I was like I just I just think we were
doing it wrong
and so I explained what had happened and
she's like so is this what we're gonna
do now and I was like I guess I was like
I can call the other 30 gyms that we did
the turnarounds for I was like they know
we can do it because we just did it for
them
and so I called all those guys up and we
did like 300 000 and sales that month
and it was basically all profit and I
covered the refunds and I covered
everything and we were like in the clear
and then and then it was just and then
all those gyms that we did that we sold
the average gym did uh thirty thousand
dollars in extra cash collected in their
first month using our our system
and so the key was that like if they
didn't have to pay the overhead of the
sales guy who's there every day at the
hotel the commission for that guy like
the rental car the deal like all the
stuff that you have to incentivize and
just like rent it out of their own gym
and work the leads themselves it became
incredibly profitable uh for them and um
and then it just took off like wildfire
like we went from like our first full 12
months of uh like January to January uh
we did 26 million Top Line 17 million in
ebitda our first 12 months like it was
it was
insane like it's hard to comprehend that
like I like that was the the moment I
had been like dead broke in her parents
house and then like
six months later I have three million
dollars in the bank account and then
like 12 months after that I've got like
20 million it was it was insane and um I
didn't even know how you could pay taxes
like I didn't I was like I was figuring
all this stuff out but through that
whole thing
Layla was just like
you can do this like we can do this like
we've got this
um and I think sometimes you just need
one voice behind you that just just
keeps believing what happened then so
that's 2016. um you turn things around
over the next couple of years what
happens you know leading up to where we
are today in terms of your business can
you give me a Top Line summary in terms
of what yeah I'll give you the tldr
um
continue to grow gym launch uh two years
later we started a sub one company
called Prestige labs at this point we
had thousands of gym owners that had
licensed the business model and the ads
and all the stuff that we were doing and
so we sold through that distribution
base that company grew pretty good
pretty big pretty quickly
um a year after that we started a
software company that also
helped gyms get leads in the doors just
like an automated lead thing
and then um 2021
[Music]
we sold all three of those companies uh
the supplement and the licensing company
we sold to American Pacific group which
is a private Equity Firm out of San
Francisco for uh 46.2 million for uh
we sold two-thirds of the company
and then the software company we
actually sold to a strategic buyer who
had like a massive base and we had a
better monetization system than they did
um and that was an all-stock deal
um so we're just
it's continuing to grow under their
umbrella and they'll probably sell them
four or five years
um but from that and what we had taken
in dividends um during the licensing
business for the five years that it was
still is rocking and rolling
we started acquisition.com so that
became kind of our family office
and so we started our first Investments
I think first event since we did was in
2020 so there is some overlap there and
part of the reason that I was willing to
sell it was because the Investments the
first
three or four Investments we did did
really well
um and I was like okay this is what I
want to do is the next thing so that you
know I didn't want to be the gym guy for
the rest of my life
um because I had been you know at this
point had been I think more than a
decade
um that I'd been from like sleeping on
the gym floor to having multiple
occasions to doing the turnaround
business to doing the licensing like I'd
been in that game for a long time and
I think that maybe I could have stayed
there and could have just continued to
compound it and start doing Acquisitions
under that Fitness umbrella but I wanted
to
do more General business stuff and so
that was uh
that's what we did and so uh now we now
we buy chunks of companies usually uh
usually minority Stakes 25 to 49ish
percent I mean we have one that we're in
the talks of that we were originally
minority stake in and we're gonna take
majority because it's been a great
company and they want to the founder in
the same position as I was like just
wants to do other stuff and it's a great
business
um and so but that's kind of how we see
it as like growth Partners
um we come in
we write a check we add value we help
grow the business what are you brilliant
at you know you kind of you kind of come
to learn what you're good at based on
comparison but you kind of understand
your area of expertise what is your area
of Brilliance or expertise
I really want to ask Caleb
um Caleb
where's Caleb we can barely see
so Caleb sat over on the sofa in the
corner of the studio he's
um friend and creative director of Alex
and I'm asking Caleb what Alex is good
at what's his error of brilliance
I like it solving problems
um for companies simplifying complex
things into more digestible actionable
um Solutions as well and how would you
answer that question if you were
answering it for yourself
I feel like I fundamentally a lot of
times don't understand the world and so
I think the reason that some people have
found the content and things like that
um good or useful is because they feel
like they can understand it it's just
because like I didn't get it right like
terms like value right people like
provide more value like what does that
mean
and so I just make it make an attempt to
define the terms that a lot of us use
every day and then it makes a lot easier
to solve for those things in business
and so you know a lot of people like I
want to grow my business I'm like all
right what does that mean like well get
more customers make them worth more okay
so it's one of those two things all
right well how do I make get more
customers like well there's eight ways
to do it here are the eight ways which
one do you feel like you're best at and
just like kind of thinking through
Frameworks that way is it's just for me
it's just been my way of being able to
be relatively competent in a world that
feels confusing
like there's a few things I feel like I
can understand and I just hold on to
those
I mean that's the very nature of
innovation isn't it like asking the
question
we so so often Our Lives just accept
words and phrases and ways of doing
things then there's a few people who are
really good like elon's one of them uh
just like asking why and then when you
ask why like why can't you make an
affordable quote electric vehicle that
is fast everyone else says you can't
yeah
but why you know and then he he's great
at breaking it down into like the core
components of that Innovation so well if
we buy the metal on the iron exchange
and we do this and this then we can do
it yeah
they said that's such an important thing
in entrepreneurship isn't it there's
some people who just ask why
naturally yeah
it seems like to the point like to Elon
it's like I don't understand why we
can't yeah like just explain to me why
we can't so that I cannot think about
this yeah and I feel like that's you
know I would say that that's the most
common thing like why isn't this company
growing like I don't get it like explain
it to me and then usually a lot of
people it's like they're they're in this
caught in this Loop you know what I mean
of doing what they've always done
um or like believing that this is the
only way
um and I think a lot of times I've
benefited from like not knowing because
I
my questions don't seem stupid to me
but only to somebody who like knows what
they're doing um it seems stupid and so
from there we're able to like I guess to
your point innovate
um
just by being like I don't understand
that's what Steve Jobs from everything
that I've read about Steve Jobs in my
brief conversation with Steve Wozniak
Once Upon a Time
um is he was just the the voice in the
room that never understood why they
couldn't
and even like when we think about him
removing the keyboard and doing you know
not refusing to use a stylus and all
these other crazy things he did not
using JavaScript I think at the time and
changing the port and removing the
iPhone Jack that that is somebody who is
so strong in their convictions in terms
of like doing things anyway how
important do you think that is generally
like what in your view what makes a
really good
um
entrepreneur leader
I think that they have to have the power
to influence and that is across lots of
things uh just they have to be able to
move other people and you can Define
sales as the ability to get people to
comply with your request you can define
leadership the same way
um management marketing to a degree is
getting people to comply with a larger
request you know publicly
um but I think that fundamentally is a
skill that people have to have if
they're going to be successful at
entrepreneurship they have to have
tremendous Drive whether that's a
combination of towards or away so they
have a big mission that they really want
to achieve or they have some very big
fear that they're running away from
either way I think the fuel works just
from a pure entrepreneurship Perspective
Third piece is impulse control
is that they have to be able to say no
to things on a regular basis for an
extended period of time
um
and I think they have to be able to boil
down the success of their business into
inputs and outputs
like if you do not know the inputs that
are going to get the output that you
want then what are you doing
and so I think for for most
entrepreneurs like if they have those
things if they have the ability to lead
other people
sell just influence
they have some big motivator they can
control themselves long enough to keep
on going during that period of time and
they're doing the right things because
they know the inputs and outputs to be
successful to create their the thing
that they want
um becomes a very difficult person to
beat
on that first point then sales one of
the things I I read um in some of your
work is this idea that if everybody just
went and spent two years doing
door-to-door sales then oh my God why is
that important why do you think
door-to-door sales is a key thing I
think it's um just for what for broader
definitions for the audience I think
it's just high volume transactional
sales so whether that's you doing
door-to-door are you cold calling
um or you working the front desk at a
gym where you do 20 consoles a day like
just having a high volume because in
order to learn a skill you want to have
as much
exposure as you can to repeat the action
and then you want quick feedback loops
so that you can learn what you did wrong
so the perfect scenario would be Mentor
mentee repeated exposure fix this try
again fix this try again and in sales if
you can survive that long then you are
good enough that you will have gotten
enough feedback like for most people if
they can weather the first three months
of sales then they'll usually be fine
and so for the people who are coming up
I always tell them like go Shadow the
best guy and do twice the volume he's
doing because you're not as good as him
so like do twice the volume that they're
doing work all of the hours and you will
get better faster because you're doing
you have to suck for X period of time
and so if you can condense how how long
that takes you in terms of calendar days
not hours you can get there faster but I
think that it's important because when
you have to learn how to get rejected
and still keep going and I think that's
a very valuable skill and then two
there's lots of like little things that
you learn in just interpersonal
communication that allow you that you
can use with teammates later you can use
in marketing because a lot of the best
marketers started as salespeople and
marketing is just sales one to many at
least as as I understand it
um
and so having that kind of repetition
just develops a deep understanding of
human psychology I think
um and I think it's important for if you
want to get people to give you money for
the thing that you have
um having that as a base skill comes in
handy
I think a lot of people aren't
orientated towards
developing skills I think they're
orientated to Lifestyle to what I can
post on Instagram
to call whatever's cool
um but this idea of developing skills
requires this thing that's kind of
absent in modern culture which is
patience and a lot like you said
rejection who wants that you know it was
there was no glamor in what you said
yeah
it's funny because a lot of us want
traits right we want to be patient we
want to be humble we want to be you know
long-suffering whatever words you want
to use
um but in order to if I would say hey
how would you
create if you had to create a human
what would you put them through to make
them tough
it probably wouldn't be a really chill
life yeah what would you put them
through to make them patient well you
probably wouldn't give them things
immediately
and so it's like we want these trades
but each of the traits has a price tag
attached to it it's just like do you
want to pay the price tag to get the
thing and so I think if if people
reframed the the period of life that
they're going through as the price that
they're paying out of their wallet but
the wallet is their time it's the
seconds of life that they're trading for
it then I think more people be willing
to make the trade because at least when
I look at myself
like when I'm 80 something years old and
I'm looking back at my life I want to
have these traits but in order to have
those traits I know I have to go through
these things and I think for me that's
given me a lot of
comfort in hard times
one of the things that kind of adjacent
to that
which causes patience is the belief that
you are at some point gonna get there so
like you know it's all well and good you
saying to me you do this for five years
Stephen you'll build the skill but I go
well listen if I want to be a
millionaire
um and I and I have a low self-belief
I'm gonna have low conviction so I'm not
even going to take the BET yeah so how
does one build that's self-belief
self-belief is such an interesting thing
because it feels like this real it's
clear to some degree that you had it in
that moment of turmoil it also the
reason I say to some degree is because
it didn't seem like you had a plan B
anyway sorry
[Laughter]
you were already in your like your
parents-in-laws like playroom or
whatever so Ain't Nothing To Lose yeah
you're nothing to lose so I don't know
how much self-belief is applicable but
regardless to keep gracing those hurdles
self you need some kind of conviction
that like this is the right way to go
how do people build that so I hear that
into like to to Echo the point you just
made
I hated my current existence and so I
think some people like don't hate their
current existence enough
and so like I don't think you know like
you either have to really believe that
this thing's going to happen or you have
to know that your life sucks
and I knew that my life sucked and so I
knew that if I did something else it
would have it would have a higher
likelihood of changing my life
than not doing something
and at least that's how I would say that
I probably saw it in the beginning it's
like I didn't know if it was going to
work but I knew that I wasn't going to
stop
I read I heard a quote some 10 years ago
which from just came to mind when you
said that on some YouTube family Vlog
where he said
change happens when the pain of staying
the same becomes greater than the pain
of making a change and in your situation
though it sounds like well this is less
painful 100 I think and I think that's
the basis of motion either you have to
have a reward that is that that
incentivizes you the way towards her
away it's either we're going away from
pain or going towards pleasure I think a
lot of people are really looking for
that passion that's gonna be towards but
I think early days and I talk a lot
about this but like I think negative
motivation is poo pooed too much like if
you are angry use it if you are sad use
it
because like what else are you gonna do
with it
like you might as well let it help you
like or it uses you you know what I mean
and so I always like to see when I was
in my earlier days I felt like I was
wielding my anger at least in a
direction and I think also a lot of
people think that they have to get like
it right on the first shot
but one of the beliefs that I had was
that I just want to be directionally
correct like if I move I like I know
that I don't like this and so this way
is not where I am and so I will start
taking steps this way and from the story
that you at least heard it's like I'll
ping-pong a little bit to try and
directionally move that way and it's
funny because Caleb's seen plenty of
things from what we do at
acquisition.com where we're like we'll
try it out and if it doesn't work
they're like oops
all good
do you believe in yourself
I think that
I have a high likelihood of repeating
activities that I've done in the past
and up to this point I have lots of
evidence that would suggest that it that
I will continue why didn't you say Yes
um because
I based the answer on that question or
what I've done before and I think it's
been it's just based on evidence now so
it's not like I like
uh Charisma thing at least for me it's
just like
I've done these things and so I think
it's probable that I'll be able to
continue
is there a deeper reason to why you
didn't just say yes
that's actually how I think about it
is that because it feels difficult to
say you believe in yourself
yeah it feels weird
I don't know if hokey is the right word
for what that feels like for me but like
saying the way that I said it is how I
is how I feel about it
have you been on the Journey of in terms
of self-doubt over over the last you
know
that he is for sure
I think it was um but I mean fear was my
big fear and anger hand in hand were my
big motivators in the beginning
and I mean maybe that's from softap I
would say that I was very certain and I
can I can I can feel this and I remember
this
um
I was always certain that I wasn't going
to stop
like that I can I didn't know
I didn't know whether I would succeed
I thought it was probable
but I did know I wasn't going to stop
and so for me that was like enough to
get me going or keep me going it's like
what are the controllables me okay well
if I do this so like I'm big on making
like unreasonable like unreasonable that
it doesn't work out statements just like
if I do sales and I do more volume than
everyone else on this team and I've
Shadow the guy who's the best and I do
that for five years it's unreasonable
that I won't be at least mediocre it
will be probable that I'm above average
and it's also probable that I'll learn
other things along the way and I'll also
have the resources at that point in five
years that I can jump into things now
that I have more context or perspective
from which to make a judgment on what a
good next opportunity is and so I like
very easy to believe statements and then
having the input output equation being
like the output is that I will be a very
good salesman the input says that I have
to do I have to collect 5 000 nodes if I
collect 5000 no's I'll be a very good
salesman and that for me like when I was
a kid when I played video games I would
beat the same level over and over and
over and over again so that when I got
to the next level I would crush
everybody because I had all the
experience points maxed out and so like
those input output equations are really
helpful for me like when I took the GMAT
to get into Harvard
my first score was like okay it wasn't
great
um but I read this study on how to do
well on standardized tests
and they had this graph and it went like
this it was just a straight line it said
number of problems practiced on
GMAT score so like the more problems you
did on average the higher your test
score was and I was like done so I
bought 16 phone books of like they're
like these thick like test prep books
and I did four hours of problems every
day for three months every day I get
home from work I'd eat dinner I would do
four hours problems I had a timer every
day and then I scored 99 Point whatever
percentile because it was just input
output like I didn't I didn't I was
naturally not even that good at math
um but I just like if I do 10 000
[__] problems like I'll start to just
understand how these problems get asked
and so like I was trying to find like
what's the input output for this the
content game I was like okay well if you
post once a day on one platform we will
get some eyeballs if we post on every
platform every day we will get more
eyeballs if we post multiple times a day
on every platform we'll get even more
eyeballs so let's do that let's build
that system 100 and so like those are
the like I try and make statements that
I believe are unreasonable that if I do
it enough it will be true and so that's
for me that's what gives me the
confidence to say like what if it's not
working like it will eventually like if
we just keep doing it it will work
what does it take to want to do
something potentially for years so that
you can get good at it
because you know there's going to be
people thinking well I want to be a
great DJ but I just can't find the
motivation to spend every day three
hours practicing Alex yeah
but then you probably won't be a good DJ
but I'd be like I would be like you like
your current state enough that you like
the pain of change thing right like
you're not in enough pain I've said that
to plenty of people we go speak and
someone's like how do I get motivated
I'm like you're gonna get motivated like
you have to hate for me if I could
already I automatically go there I'm
like you have to hate something like for
me I just hated my current existence and
so for me that was powerful enough to
get me out there's got to be another way
though you know I was thinking to you
that moment where you took the leap you
know there's I feel I often feel like
most people that listen to this podcast
often are at a point in their life where
they're considering a leap yeah feel
like we drag those type of people in we
kind of like we're a magnet to those
people so if they if they're in a
situation that they don't like but it's
not that painful you know it's
comfortable well that's the worst it's
comfortable but a little bit miserable
yeah how do you get them to take the
leap when it's so comfortable
my boss is promising me a promotion
I think about death all the time
it's like I'm going to die
and I think you have to agitate the pain
for yourself
like you have to stoke the pain
like if you can't get through through
because like it would be it would be odd
that you would be motivated by some
weird passion like not everyone's Mozart
and just like I do love music and I've
been I see and you know see numbers and
colors you know whatever like some
people are like that but most people
aren't and so if you're not that
then
you only start really liking stuff when
you get good at it in my opinion and you
only get good at it by doing it a lot of
times before you're good at it
and so if you
this is why I'm a big big believer in
this is that when you are starting out I
think you got to find the thing that's
the pain and like pain motivates
significantly faster and stronger than
pleasure does like people like no
passions the right way it's like point a
gun at a family member all of a sudden
10 out of 10 motivation pain
and so like I think people should use
their pain more and if they don't have
enough pain then one maybe that's fine
and you're a dreamer and that's okay but
I will tell you that a word that I can I
read in my like six month Journey
between when I wanted to quit and when I
actually quit there was this word that
just like pissed me off and it was this
in this self-hop or entrepreneur book
and it said there are entrepreneurs and
there are entrepreneurs
and it was like entrepreneurs or people
who read these books and don't do
anything and I was just like I don't
want to be I was like I am one of these
right now and I just it just like felt
so
powerless
and I think that my entire life has been
a lot of trying to
have power
and I mean that in the true sense of
just being able to direct influence and
events I've wanted to have more power to
protect myself protect the people I care
about Etc
um and I felt very powerless and I think
that I was in that comfortable like my
dad approves of my current situation I
had a job that when I told people
they're like oh that's fancy but I felt
powerless
and I I hated that more than anything
and so I think I think if
I want to say this to anyone who's
listening if there's anything you listen
to
all the stuff that I described that was
really tough that I went through was not
as hard as me quitting my job
by far the hardest decision of my entire
life bar none
because the things that I was actually
caught up with were the opinions of
other people opinions of my father and
the opinions of the people that I went
to school with who I thought would judge
me for leaving this good job to probably
become a failed gym owner and how lame
that would sound compared to consultant
going to Harvard and like I was going to
go from Peak white collar to
a very blue color you know profession
making significantly less because I
quote loved it
and
like if I I'll say this again but like
sometimes you have to let other people's
dreams for your life die for years to
live and for me it was like when I
when I continued to every day not want
to wake up that was my wake-up call
where I was like either I continue to
live this way and not want to be alive
or
I just risked the fact that I'll die to
everybody else and I think that that
like it was the hardest decision in my
entire life by far all this all the hard
stuff we went through still the hardest
decision in my life how much was money
on your mind when you made that decision
the desire to be financially free to the
point where you had Millions
it's weird money um Caleb would know
this money doesn't really motivate me uh
I would say that I mean I love the game
for sure
um but I love playing the game and the
tokens are there
um
but for me it was it was
it was it was beating my dad you know I
mean I didn't want him to be right like
that's what it was like I didn't want
him to be right
I just I just I remember like I'd be
sleeping on the floor I'd be miserable
at you know when I had my gym and I had
no trainers I was teaching all the
classes and so I'd wake up I'd do 4am 5
AM 6 AM 7 8 AM sessions and then I would
then uh work out for myself and then I
would uh do uh I do all the marketing
and the ads and the stuff that I have to
do in the middle day and then I would
teach the fourth the four pm the 5 PM
description to 7 p.m and then I would do
sales consults at 8 9 10 11 and then I'd
do the billing for all the all the
contracts from 11 to like 12 12 30 and
then I'd wake up again and I did that
for like six months and like I started
like lose my mind because I wasn't
sleeping
um but even during like those times I
just literally I would Envision going
back to Baltimore to my father
and have and knowing that he would give
me the false modesty of like well I know
you tried don't worry about it now let's
get you back on this thing and I knew
that from that moment on he would own me
and I just couldn't I couldn't I
couldn't do it I was like I will do
anything but go back to that
and for me that was my
I would do anything
and so whatever that maybe you need to
agitate some pain in your life you know
to get out of your current circumstance
um and just as a total side note
play it out what if you just never do
anything
is like maybe some people just need to
stop dreaming
maybe they need to accept their current
reality and actually enjoy it
because there's a lot of people when
they're 70 and 80 and they didn't do
their dreams and if they went back like
they didn't do anything but that whole
time they were dissatisfied because they
didn't try
but what if they were just like I have a
good life I have a wife who loves me
I've got some kids I have a job that I
you know like I don't mind it pays the
bills I mean if you go back 500 years
there wasn't people like man this is my
passion he's like dude I'm just rowing
rowing a boat across a ferry and that's
what I do and that's what my dad did and
his dad did like this is how we eat and
so like we have these these um idealized
versions of purpose that I think
Instagram and all this stuff kind of
make terrible but like I think there's a
lot of honor and work period And I think
a lot of people uh fool themselves by
thinking you know what they do for some
reason is not honorable
and I think a lot of it is like the
internal versus external scorecard of
like
I was saying what I said earlier about
like I believe these things to be true
about the universe or like the world but
a lot of those are like what do I
believe about myself which is like I can
choose to do work in this way which then
I can derive Joy from so like if I'm
Shoveling [__]
I can choose to be like I will be the
best [__] shoveler because I believe
that I will figure out how to do this
more efficiently and I will you know I
will I will get better and I'll have
calluses on my hands and I'll have a
better back and whatever
um but I will do this well
and I think
you can find joy and work if you decide
to do it well so on one hand
if you are if you were if your dream
causes you so much pain then you will
quit what you're doing and do it and if
it doesn't cause you enough pain that
you're not pursuing it or that you don't
like if you don't feel like you're in a
cage right now
then maybe you're not in a cage and
maybe you just need to like the life you
have and
that's cool too a previous guest on this
podcast called mogow that said we're
unhappy when our expectations of how we
think life is supposed to be going are
unmet
and in that
there's something very sort of linked to
what you just said there which is we
have this external expectation set by
Instagram or whatever by People Like Us
yeah
who who are in a position of um
Financial Freedom and have built an
audience who you know admire those
people for what they've achieved and if
someone wants to be admired they think
well I need to be like Alex right
um and that I could be working in a shop
actually objectively like subjectively
having a great time in the shop but I
look up at Alex and go my life sucks
right and like so in that I'm like it's
very difficult
um because of the pressure effect's done
like I was just thinking when you said
it then I was thinking this whole idea
of like passion and purpose is probably
like 60 years old yeah make believe it's
all brand new
and it probably originated when we were
like connected you know like radio TV
yeah all of this ad me advertising which
made us change our expectations of our
own lives when living in the village and
like helping out at the bakery was
probably delivered the same amount of
Happiness core happiness than being on
the private jet and whatever else does
now
I think most people are just as happy
and just like you're 50 happy 50 sad for
most of your life if you're in an
extreme circumstance then change your
life if you're not like
conditions like people get handicapped
they break their legs you know they can
never move again and they have a dip in
their subjective well-being and they go
back to the same Baseline and so like
the Baseline is independent of
conditions
and so the world wants to tell us that
we need to change our you know change
our circumstances and then we will be
whatever but like every modern religion
every Buddhist monk will tell you that
all of that's from the inside not the
outside
um but these are words and words that
mean you yeah can say don't follow yeah
because I'm sure that you've you've
experienced like the attainment of a
goal and then I just need three times
more yeah I'm referencing a study there
where they they ask people how much
money they would need to be happy and
all the way up the income wealth
Spectrum people said three times more
than they have now so people with 10K
said 30 people with 3 million said you
know sick nine million I can do math
three times three times three yeah
um
and you you I imagine you still
experience that now right yeah
different reasons but yeah for sure when
is enough enough
um I don't think it's enough thing I
think it's more like who I want to be
who do you want to be
I want to be the person capable of
doing that doing X
like we'll get to a billion and then
after a billion I'll make it 10. I
already know that you don't remember
like
I love playing the game what is the game
game of business
to what to what end or just just for the
play to play yeah I'm sure you know more
about this than I do but like just Game
Theory like the if
finite and infinite games Simon sinek
has a great piece on it
um
but yeah with infinite games you have
known and unknown players you have no
read upon rules and the point of the
game is to keep the game going
and so a lot of students people will
take a finite game where you have known
only known players agreed upon rules and
a set outcome
um
for winning and they will apply it to an
infinite game so people are like I want
to they apply a finite contract to
health they're like I want to win Health
it's like you don't win Health like okay
you're in shape now what you stay in
shape you keep staying in shape I want
to win at marriage you don't win at
marriage you keep the marriage going
that's playing the game of marriage if
you want to you know Win It Business
keep playing the game of business and so
we want to take these finite contracts
and put them on on infinite games and I
think that's where people get it get in
trouble because they're they're like I
have to keep moving the goal post but if
the goal post is to play then you win by
playing and so for that like sure we set
goals for the company but like I'm a
thousand percent super motivated and at
the same time we never hit it I'm just
gonna be happy that I was able to play I
also know that in three generations
everyone will forget who I am
I saw your post about the queen yeah
no no no it wasn't for me if I've been
honest
um but uh but it's an interesting con
what did the post say was she amassed
more wealth than 99.99 of the world she
ruled for 70 years uh was you know a
female Monarch which is insane
especially seven years ago just like
it's all it's had amazing family all
this amazing whatever I don't know the
tabloids you do
um
and when I posted it had been I think
five or six months since she had died
exactly
and I was like you probably haven't
thought about her today except for this
post she probably accomplished more in
her life than we probably will
so if you are afraid of other people
thinking about you just remember the six
months after you died they're not going
to be and so it's like we have all these
fears about other people but like most
of them won't even trip to your funeral
because they're going to be busy
and so like I I think about death all
the time and that's that's what I think
for me has given me a lot of uh freedom
to take big shots
because like at the end of the day I
think that it's not going to matter no
one's going to remember people in
Thailand don't know who I am today let
alone in five ten years 100 years
it's a trap that the mind can quite
easily fall into though thinking you are
the center of the universe and with that
comes an immense amount of weight and
pressure and anxiety totally I I have a
trick I've never talked about this
before but whenever I feel
myself slipping into the Trap of
kind of overstating my importance what I
mean by that is like thinking my
problems are big problems I go on
YouTube and I type in
um
there's this one video that shows a
camera on Earth that just zoom out and
it keeps going and eventually Earth
becomes this tiny Speck then the Earth
becomes this tiny Speck which is the
Galaxy then the Galaxy becomes this tiny
Speck and a bunch of galaxies then you
can't see any of it anymore
and then also this idea that like 100
years ago I didn't feel anything didn't
think anything nobody knew me 100 years
from now exactly what you said
absolutely I mean [__] five minutes
after I die I think
but um and that feels really liberating
like relieves of stress from my body
which is an interesting thing because a
lot of people don't like thinking about
the death you know a lot of thinking
about it yeah all the time I know from
doing this podcast that a lot of people
won't click if we we post something
about death they won't because they
don't even want to confront the concept
of it which is
people are afraid of it just because
they don't understand it
it's kind of like the Hate Thing how do
you feel about death I'm good with it
when you say I'm good with it what do
you mean
if I die tomorrow I'm good with it
like
I want to leave it all on the field
I'm gonna try as hard as I can and I
know that
no one remember me on a long enough time
Horizon
and I'm good with that
like I'm cool with it
if I told you you're gonna die tomorrow
would you be sad
I'd probably hang out with Layla a
little I guess a little more than I
always do but like
um I would say I wouldn't be sad I'd be
bummed I'd be like man there's all the
[__] I want to do uh but I don't think
I'd be like depressed I think I mean my
dude to be fair maybe I'll find out and
maybe I'll get hit by a bus tomorrow but
um no I think like
I've lived life the way I want to live
life
and
I'm good with it if you were to go today
had you really like given it everything
had you lived the life you feel like you
were really destined to live
me absolutely
an interesting Mind Trick around the
same topic is
so when when Betty White dies right at
99 or whatever like people were like she
lived a good life but when Kobe dies
before his time right it's a big deal
and I see that as a contrast between
expectations and reality
and I'm going to tell a story that
hopefully people don't take the wrong
way but I had a cat and really liked the
cat and it died at two years old
really liked it young guy heart thing or
something whatever
I remember being like really bummed
about it and I was like huh
how can I not think this and so I was
like the only reason I'm bummed is
because I think that he should have
should being the the big word that
Everyone likes to use he should have
lived longer I was like
what if cats only lived six months and I
got to have him for two years I was like
I'd probably be pretty stoked about that
and all of a sudden I was significantly
less sad about it I was like I got to
have him for two years I was like
awesome
and so I think
like for for me for us whatever
um if we were to change our expectation
like people think they should live until
everyone thinks they're gonna live to
100 which is kind of interesting because
like the average life expectancy 74 and
if you're like 36 you're middle aged if
you actually do the math which no one
wants to do uh being middle-aged at 36.
all right I know right yeah but I think
if we shift our expectations that like
expectations is the thing it's it's the
thing right and so we can if we expected
if I expected that I was supposed to
have lived 20 years and I made it to 33.
stoked
Jesus lived until third three he did a
lot more than I have you know what I
mean and so
I'm good with it if I die tomorrow like
only reason I would be upset is is if I
demanded from the universe that I live
longer
but like 500 years ago average life
expectancy was like 35 you know it was
just not like Dark Ages ladies and
gentlemen I am so delighted to finally
be able to announce that one of my
all-time favorite brands are now
sponsoring this podcast and that is
whoop all of you know that I've been on
a bit of a journey in terms of health
performance cognitive performance sleep
and all those kinds of things that's
kind of been reflected in the guests
we've had on this podcast and whoop has
been a huge part of my life for many
many many years that's part of the
reason I also had the founder come on
the podcast after having will on the
podcast I love the brand even more
hearing about his vision his passion for
the project where it came from his own
Obsession was solving a problem which
turned into the product that is whoop
whoop is a wearable health and fitness
coach that provides you with the
feedback and real actionable insights
into sleep into recovery into how you're
training into your stress levels and
your overall health and for me it's
empowered me to be the best version of
myself across all of those aspects of my
life the woot team have very kindly off
to give all of you a free month so just
head to join.woop.com CEO to claim your
device and your first free month on us
working hard we talked about repetitions
earlier working hard is quite a
controversial Topic in 2023
it's weird do you see what I mean though
yeah
I'm probably not in the circles where
it's controversial
they're like gravity's controversial I'm
like I don't know
it's controversial in the sense that
there's like toxic work oh my God you
know there's toxic hard work and there's
I think Society prescribes a certain
amount of work which is good
yeah
by their definition of like I'm going to
say some stuff that's going to bother
some people I work all the time I have
no Hobbies besides working out if you
consider that a hobby like four times a
week that's it I work all the time
that's all I do and I work until I can't
work meaning like my output per unit of
time starts to drop precipitously and
then I know that I just need to take a
break of some sort and then I usually
been some sort of Television because
that's what for me Works some people are
like I Garden that's not me Netflix I'm
good you know what I mean or dark room
in a movie theater rocking
um
comma and that's okay like why do I need
to take their expectation of what they
want like they're like that's not
healthy I'm like Define healthy I do as
much as I can of the thing that I want
to do with every minute of my day
why is that not healthy why do you want
me to do something that I would prefer
to do less
because I do what I do every other day
because that's what I want to do
almost like how dare you cast your
expectation of your life unto me
and to be fair the same degree
they cannot work at all doesn't affect
me like I'm a I'm a big big advocate for
destroying should the word
in general
should it's just like the expectation
motor of like all of our psyches you
should go to school you should get a
degree you should do this job you should
marry her you shouldn't stay up so late
you shouldn't work so hard you shouldn't
you should be more balanced you
shouldn't be working out so much you're
not working out like it's there's all
these shoulds that other people tell us
and it's like and you zoom out and then
you see that it's a galaxy with a little
dot of dust it's like should what
there is no should do what you want to
do at least that's how I see the world
that pressure applies to both ends of
the spectrum doesn't it because people
that quote unquote overwork they get hit
come back into the middle and that
people that under work they get hit work
harder and then the presumption they're
in within Society is that there's this
sweet area in the Middle where it's
optimal and like the question should
become then like what is the measurement
like what are we measuring
is it are we measuring when we're
defining this amount of work as good
work or healthy or whatever
is the is the real measurement my
happiness and my fulfillment
in your view is that what you're like is
that your measurement or is it just
[__] how you feel
I work because I enjoy working
and I'm sure that if I stop enjoying
working I won't work as much like just
being really like not being I'm not
being simplistic to be you know Annoying
um
I work because I enjoy working
and if I and if for some reason I didn't
get reinforced them from work I'm sure
that my amount of work would go down is
there is there a I think about like
human needs yeah but are there any human
needs that
are being sacrificed by always working
in your case
I'm good
um yeah I mean
which gets to the point of the
measurement which is like how do I feel
I'm good
yeah I a lot of people really over
analyze a lot of things and like I don't
think well I do I do I do spend a lot of
time thinking about death and things
like that but I usually use those as
frames to give myself permission to do
the things that I want to do
and just do them without hearing the
Judgment that I know that other people
would probably cast on my life they're
like why don't you have kids
because I haven't wanted to yet
and that's okay and if I want to later I
will
I'll tell okay I'll tell you an argument
that I got into so I was at you got into
an argument I did I got into an argument
um with my stepmother so Leila's
father's
whatever it doesn't matter
okay it wasn't her different person it's
fine
anyways I was at in the kitchen table
and
she said
I would never want your life
and I was like what she was like it's so
unbalanced I was like
okay
how I was like do you feel like I'm not
in shape physically
I was like do you feel like
business-wise financially I'm I'm not
fit
do you feel like romantically like my
marriage is in some way like not good
and so I I like would where do you feel
like I'm unbalanced or it's just that I
do more than you
or I do things differently than you do
because the same degree I wouldn't want
your life and that's why I don't have
your life and that's why you don't have
my life so it's good that we don't want
to each other's lives because that would
be tough wouldn't it
and so that was the argument that we got
into in in so many words and it just
came down to the idea that like I think
that person was casting judgment on
themselves
because maybe on some level maybe they
did want some aspect of the life that we
had and I hope that doesn't sound like
weird but it's just like I think we all
do this we see something we're like and
then we look at our Delta and then we
either say man I would like that or we
cast stones at it so that we don't feel
bad to our ego and so like no there's
something wrong with it
they're not happy
whatever and I just I would say that if
there's one thing that I I will try and
beat out of me until I die is caring
what other people think and I think
everybody cares what other people think
and I think over time we just care a
little bit less and so I feel like I'm
30 better than I was 10 years ago and
maybe in 10 years I'll be like 30 better
than that
but that 30 has been very meaningful for
me because it's enabled me to do things
like I got married in eight days none of
my parents were there
and I'm cool with it
because that's what I wanted to do and I
work with my wife every hour of every
day and people are like is that healthy
I'm like I don't know we like it why do
you care like how does it affect you
he's he's a trap though yeah I can
relate in many yeah in many ways to what
you're saying and I mean my team will
know that instinctively um what are the
traps we can fall into one of the risks
when we have that perspective is that we
kind of cast that expectation on others
people that work with us
I think entrepreneurs oftentimes when
they have that
Drive which is sometimes driven by a
shame or an insecurity that comes from
their childhood too often
um so often maybe not too often but so
often
um that when they lead people who don't
have that same insecurity shame whatever
that
predisposition to you know workaholism
whatever you want to call it
they struggle to relate
you know yeah have you have you heard
that sure
but I think that's okay
have you had to work on that
Layla's better
I say that Jessica but like
realistically I think we try to maintain
a culture of high performance and we're
like on the screening Parts on the front
end we're like these are the values we
have here are examples of those values
at play so it's like if your shift ends
at five
and somebody asks a question that's
going to take 30 minutes to answer at 4
59 what do you do
it's an interview question we're like
and we need you to be honest because if
you say you would work but you would
actually be dissatisfied you're not
going to do either of us Justice because
you'll come in and you'll get fired
quickly and that'll be hard for you and
hard for us
so like we want you to win at whatever
you do in life so Layla is very big on
like human first in terms of how she
does everything that we do in the
company is like human first then
everything else
you can tell that's why like we're yin
and yang for this this kind of thing
um
but I think it's really just about
expectation setting and being very
truthful and as transparent as humanly
possible about like this is what we
expect if you don't like that or if your
worldview is contrary to this then you
shouldn't work here because there's
another company that totally shares your
worldview and you would do great there
and there's other people who feel like
Misfits in the companies that they're in
and then work all the time and they're
frustrated that no one else does and
they're all like
telling them they should slow down
come hang with us because we'll we'll
respond slack at 5am on Saturday because
we're on that's but like I just I just
hardcore reject there is a right way to
do things
in that example you've touched on
something I wanted to talk about which
relates to your first book I believe
offers making office to people yeah
I read that you said um if there's one
skill you have it's making offers
what do you mean by making offers
so uh offers are the terms of Exchange
so I
right before I started my first gym I
went to this weekend Workshop to learn
how to Market and get this this is 2013.
it was on Facebook ads
and so I got lucky so I learned how to
run Facebook ads in 2013. two weeks
before I started my gym
this is when you're getting Penny clicks
and you could put a girl with a bikini
and say weight loss click here and it
would run
and so at this thing I hadn't opened my
gym yet and the guy was like a gym
marketing dude
and he said do you want to know another
secret to sales because you could see I
was way over my head all the other guys
there were gym owners except for May and
I was like yeah because I never at that
point had never sold anything I didn't
even know the word sales was a thing
that's how out of it I was and so he
pulled me over the side and he asked me
that question I like pulled my notebook
out to like learn the secret to sales as
though it was one line and it kind of
was
he said make people an offer they'd be
they'd feel stupid saying no to
and I like wrote it down and highlighted
it and that actually became like a core
concept that we do in every business in
every business that we have which is
like how can we make this offer better
how can we
make it more valuable and that was why
defining value was such a key thing
because people like provide more value
make valuable content I'm like what does
this mean and so we boiled down
value into four variables and then
there's things that enhance value but
like core variables and then things that
enhance it so like one is like what is
the overall dream outcome of the the
customer and so a difference in
juxtaposition is like for guys if I say
I can help you make more money versus I
can help you lose weight most guys would
pay more for the thing that will give
them more relative status and so in that
way between two types two categories of
outcomes this one will be more valuable
okay cool now within everything and
let's call it weight loss because that's
an easy one everyone can understand
within weight loss
every other thing between a five dollar
ebook and a fifty thousand dollar
liposuction surgery the difference in
those prices are the other value
variables and so the second variable is
perceived likert of achievement which is
if I buy this thing How likely do I
think I will get the outcome and so if I
have a surgeon that's going to do this
liposuction for example and it's the
first surgery they've done out of
medical school and there's another
surgeon that has done ten thousand and
has ten thousand five stars
which one would I be more likely to go
to the ten thousand five star surgery
even if it actually takes that guy less
time to do it how unfair but my
perceived liket of getting what I want
is significantly higher so it's actually
the equal opposite of risk
those are the things that we try and
enhance in the offers we try and have a
very compelling dream outcome try and
make it very likely that they're going
to succeed and give there's lots of
elements that make someone feel like
it's likely they'll succeed
on the bottom half of the equation so
it's a fraction there's two on the top
two on the bottom
you have time delay between when they
buy and when they get so
if someone were able to click a button
on a website and immediately look at
their stomach and have a six-pack that
would be incredibly valuable right on
the flip side if it takes them two years
in order to get that it's significantly
less valuable and so for that same
reason you have to arm wrestle someone
to get them to buy a personal training
package is to spend an hour and a half
to get them to buy a 20 pack of trading
trading sessions whereas
women walk into the doctor's office to
do liposuction and drop 20 times that
amount of money because the time delay
is nothing you get on the table you wake
up and you're thin right
then the last the last variable is
effort and sacrifice which is two sides
of the same coin so effort are the
things that you have to start doing that
you don't want to do as a result of this
purchase waking up early
getting sore like in the workout example
eating Foods you hate on the flip side
the sacrifice are the things that you
have to give up that you don't want to
give up as a result of this purchase and
so that might be sleeping in eating the
foods you enjoy Margarita Mondays
whatever and so when you look at these
variables each of them has a has a has a
evil twin right so you've got perceived
like a Vegeta which is the positive and
then you've got risk which is the
negative you've got time delay which is
the negative version you've got speed
which is the positive version you've got
effort and sacrifice you've got ease
right and so when we're trying to make
an offer we try and think through each
of these elements of value and think how
can we maximize the upside make it super
super likely they're going to hit it
paint the vision that they have it and
then on the bottom side minimize
the time delay between when they bind
when they get and how much they have to
do because in a perfect world The Moment
someone says I want that thing that
beautiful dream outcome they'd be
virtually guaranteed they would get it
it would happen immediately and it would
be effortless and I think that is the
perfect idea that we look at in terms of
value and as entrepreneurs we innovate
our way to just keep trying to Chisel
towards that perfect ideal outcome that
we'll never actually get to the other
variables are like scarcity if I have
one gatorade bottle left on planet Earth
it's significantly more valuable I
didn't change anything about the bottle
itself but it's significantly more
valuable than if there's unlimited
Gatorades right
urgency is if Gatorade no matter how
many Gatorades there were on planet
Earth I'll give a different example if
JK Rowling decides that uh she's no
longer going to sell Harry Potter
digital copies ever again as of tomorrow
there will be a lot of sales of the
digital copy even though there's
unlimited units
scarcity is a function of units urgency
is a function of time and so scarcity
and urgency add to the value by
enhancing those other four variables
there's more but like those are the core
things that we look at in terms of when
we're trying to make an offer uh for a
business and so
that becomes very relevant when we're
trying to increase price for a business
that we take on so I'll give you an
example we had a PR Company that we
invested in that was a generic PR
Company for like small business owners
and they had really high churn but they
had a really good sales engine I was
like okay like there's something here
but like I think we need a tweet I just
really like the founder
85 of their customers were small
business owners and turned out in like
three or four months 15 of their
customers bought the most expensive
package and stayed like forever
and I was like hey crazy idea what if we
only served these customers and they
were people who wanted to get
fundraising very different than the
traditional like dry cleaning store
polymer or whatever
and so we redid the entire business
model around finding only that Niche we
only cold called cold emailed people who
were in that very narrow window were
able to 10x our prices
because we and we got higher response
rates to the emails than we did before
because now we were targeting and
speaking very specifically to an avatar
and now we can provide so much more
value to that specific person and so
that's the maybe if Caleb were to answer
the from a business perspective like
solving that equation is probably the
thing that I enjoy the most because it
is
how
I feel like I've unlocked the most value
in a business which is like what are all
this what are all the good things that
this business has what are all the
things it can do okay
is there a way that we can rearrange it
for a specific customer that will make
significantly that will make what we do
significantly more valuable to them and
then that's what we try and repackage
and when we do that that's oftentimes
when we can like with gym launch for me
I had the knowledge of how to help
people lose weight have the the
nutrition plans I knew how to sell I
knew how to Market but it was only when
I like rearrange the variables that I
went from making a few million dollars a
year in Topline revenue and basically no
profit
to millions and millions and millions of
dollars a year in Top Line and bottom
line profit simply by rearranging the
variables and that was just so ingrained
in me that from that point going forward
I was like I just have to make things
that are so good that people will feel
stupid saying no and if we can't get
enough people to say yes we need to make
the offer better and to me that's been
like the single thing that it affects
all aspects of the business it's the
highest leverage thing I think you can
do in the business which is why it was
the first book because answering the
question what do I sell
is the first book the second book leads
is to whom do I sell it
I gotta get leads right and that's the
second book but that affects pricing it
affects profit effects marketing it
affects sales affects delivery like
getting the offer affects everything and
it's one of the hardest things to change
because it affects everything but it
also has the most ability to unlock
incredible wealth or value in a business
and the concept there is incredibly
transferable when you're going through
the equation kind of in some parts
similar to an equation we used to have
for competitions when we were trying to
get people to sign up to competitions
the idea when we saw it like a it was an
equation where on one end little
investment so just click here and you're
entered High perception that um you have
a chance of winning so if there's 10
prizes and you can see those 10 entrants
your brain goes okay all I had to do was
click and then
um in the competition aspect we thought
a lot about credibility because that's a
big factor in competitions like do I
think anyone's gonna win and do I trust
these people to even give out a prize
um and it's even the same thing and it's
even the same thing in
content
when you're thinking about a title for
your YouTube videos
five minutes six pack abs
yeah it's a fantastic equation a little
investment high potential reward
apparently
um and that's also you know there's even
another thing which I've thought about
which I've not been able to necessarily
explain which is why people are more
likely to click on things I guess it's
ease when it says things like five steps
to finding love versus like how to find
love five steps I guess it's that ease
Point feels more accessible just five
steps yeah pursue negative achievement
like what's my risk of not achieving if
there's five steps that feels easier
than just how to maybe hmm
when you um
when you think about
where you are in your journey
um as an entrepreneur
and you think about it maybe as like
Steps
how far are you at that staircase
would you not know
I was like I I felt like that was going
to be the question that you were going
to ask and I was thinking I was like I
feel like every entrepreneur feels like
they're just getting started like you
talk to guys in their 70s they're like
I'm just getting started you know
um I mean I I'm about to cross a decade
of being I am right just at the decade
point for me from the first business I
started to now
um so I feel like I've got a few seasons
left you know if I can keep living uh
which I'd be stoked about if I can
um let me ask a different question Caleb
in the corner who works for you who's
your creative director if Caleb said to
me you know Caleb said to you he said
Alex
I want to be a millionaire yeah
what would you say to him what advice
would you give to him he says listen
I've heard you doing all these podcasts
you're running around I've been filming
the camera but I've been filming I've
been listening yeah and this millionaire
stuff this sounds amazing yeah so what
advice how old are you Caleb
what advice would you give to 29 year
old Caleb if he said to you Alex how do
you knowing me how do you think I become
a millionaire so there's a lot of ways
to do it it just depends on which way
you want to go
so say first off you can stay at
acquisition.com that'll probably happen
on a long enough time Horizon just
because we're gonna get really big we're
already pretty big and we're just
getting started
um so like I genuinely believe that and
that's 100 my goal is that every single
person that that we have
um
becomes very very wealthy because I'm
going to die and it's not going to
matter anyways and if everybody else can
make some too great
um so that is a path
another bath is he peels off and goes on
his own and starts a business of some
sort and so it depends on whether he
wants to make the business itself what
his core skill is which would be like
media and maybe services around Media or
using the skill that he has of media
in an opportunity to get to two or three
other people to maybe co-founded with
who have other complementary skills and
then he just runs that division or
portion of the business uh within the
larger context and that's like a classic
question of like I'm really good at
making wallets like what do I do it's
like well you can continue to make them
and then when you can't make as many as
you have demand because you're so good
at it you can either raise the price
and just continue to keep raising the
prices until eventually become Versace
of of wallets and you make tons of
profit but you don't have tons of units
and that's okay and you're a luxury
brand or you put on the put on the
business owner hat and you say okay how
do I mechanize the wallet building
process and I become more businessy and
so I think it's like do I want to be the
artist or do I want to be the
entrepreneur both of them are fine it
depends which one you feel like you're
more naturally inclined to or have a
higher likelihood of success doing I
like the game of business I've played
lots of different games in terms of
Industries like I like the game overall
I don't feel like I have a particular
art like I don't think I'm really good
at any aspect of business
I feel like I've been decent enough to
not make one of them the constraint like
I'm not a great copywriter but I'm good
enough that that's not going to be the
limiter like I'm I'm good enough like
I'm good enough at hiring that I can
make sure that that's not the limiting
factor right and so that's kind of how I
think about it in terms of business
growth overall and so it'd be the same
thing with Caleb is like we have to
identify with the constraint of the of
the system is and then deconstrain it
when you say Talent stacking if I do say
that a few times what do you mean by
that
so
this is one of my favorite topics
um
many skills like one plus one equals
five when you put them together so let's
say you have somebody who's really good
at math in the beginning that as a skill
not super monetizable right okay well
then you learn bookkeeping okay well now
you had a proclivity for math but you
learned something that has value in the
business World okay then you learn to
you know get your CPA now you become an
accountant okay more valuable
um then you start studying around uh tax
law and insurance and you're like oh
significantly more valuable then you
learn how to how Capital markets work
and how debt markets work right and and
you understand how mergers and
Acquisitions work and all of a sudden
you are a CFO and then you learn how to
sell and promote a little bit all of a
sudden now you're a Rainmaker and so you
still needed to be good at math but when
you stack these other skills on top of
it
the original math skill becomes
significantly more valuable when you
have these skills on top but each one
kind of requires the one before which is
why one of the things I hate about kind
of the entrepreneurial World a little
bit is like they'll learn something new
and then poo poo the thing before it's
like I'm not upset but the teacher who
taught me arithmetic because I learned
algebra one was necessary for the next
and so
um
as entrepreneurs a lot of times it takes
I think the self-awareness to say like
where am I at on my skill stacking
Adventure right and each skill every
skill you add to your skill tool belt
makes the rest of your skills more
valuable which is why I think it's so
cool which is why I'm such a big
advocate for Education overall that's I
mean mission of acquisition economic
business accessible to everyone that's
why we put all this free stuff out there
is because like if we can give people
enough skills they'll be able to stack
them on their own and then just achieve
whatever they want in a totally
different way if you allow me to go
there it's like you look at Jay-Z right
maybe you're somebody who naturally had
Rhythm right and so then all of a sudden
he learned how to rap okay took his
rhythm put in a wrap okay and then he
made his first CD okay and then he
learned how to promote oh significantly
more valuable and then he learned how to
make a label and then you learn how to
recruit other artists and so he still
needed to learn how to know how to
promote
the other artists if you didn't know how
to promote it all you wouldn't be able
to do it but once he had the label he
got significantly more leverage on the
skill of promotion and he could
recognize people because of his skill in
rapping in Rhythm and so like each of
these scale stacks on top and then
eventually he he pinnacled into Beyonce
as his top skill I'm just kidding um
but no but like that's the idea so like
it and that's why I'm just like learn
the skill find the next skill and and
the nice thing is that
it doesn't even matter how disparate the
skills are like if Jay-Z is really good
at math and understands Capital markets
and understands the label those combined
to into another cool melange my little
French word like mix of skills that's
like unique to Jay-Z and the longer you
play the game the more skills you get
and the more unique you are mix of
skills is and that to me is like the
coolest part about business and just
like education in general
I I stumbled across a bit of a similar
but maybe adjacent idea
um in my career where uh when I learned
when my company went public on a Stock
Exchange in um Europe I then learned
from an investment Bank when we were
having the meetings with the banks
we went on this Roadshow met 20
different investment Banks we were
considering an IPO in another country
they told me that our business would be
worth four times more if it was just on
a different stock market if you move it
to the NASDAQ the exact same business
would be worth four times more which
meant that my net worth would be forexed
just by taking the exact same business
and moving it to a different Stock
Exchange and I thought about that a
couple of years later when I was
thinking about the skill set that I had
acquired over my career which was this
skill set of marketing and social media
and Entrepreneurship and I was thinking
you have to not just have the skill but
know what Market to apply it to and what
ended up happening I've never told this
story before but um
I looked I looked for an industry where
my skill set was in lease Supply but
highest demand and returned the greatest
and it turned out that industry in terms
of social media marketing and
storytelling I felt was most in demand
and would return the greatest value
for companies that were about to IPO
because essentially when you're going to
IPO if you have a good story it can
swing your valuation by hundreds of
millions or in the case of the first
company I worked with when their IPO
listed at 3 billion
um billions yeah and so my skill set of
social media and marketing I could do
what with it I could go help a local gym
and get paid a thousand bucks or I could
go help a company that was in the
lead-up to an IPO that was you know
where I can potentially add hundreds of
millions of value and take seven million
yeah as part of an equity deal so upon
leaving my first company the equity
Arrangement that I had was valued
somewhere between four uh I'm gonna say
between Miss Penske is a share price
fluctuated but I think on the day of the
IPO the equity that I got for for the
nine to 12 months work that I'd done was
worth in the region of seven to eight
million dollars right
nine months work yeah basically
freelance yeah
you know same skill stack but applied to
an industry that would pay me more for
the same skills
um and so I thought a lot about that and
that's ultimately why we start our
company which is now called flight story
we have a um probably the time of the
Airing there's about a hundred people we
started the company about about a year
and a half ago oh crazy and that's
basically that's applying the skill set
we have to Industries where that need it
and we started out in the IPO Market did
a little bit of work in this um biotech
Market
um and now we've kind of broadened out
but people don't think about that a lot
you like my skill set where is it in
highster morning can pay the most
a hundred percent I thoroughly agree
with everything you just said I also
think that that's a skill
like I wish someone just said it to me
like oh yeah totally and that's like
information to me it's like the most
like uh you know the biggest debt one of
the things that I um I love saying this
but like the biggest debt all of us pay
is ignorance and so I I heard this close
at this pitch years ago and this guy got
on stage and he and he was like Hey
ma'am she was like how much do you make
she was like fifty thousand dollars so
you're at fifty thousand dollars on the
Whiteboard and then you wrote a million
dollars on top of the fifty thousand and
he subtracted it it said 950 000. he
said you pay life 950 000 every single
year for not knowing how to make a
million dollars a year
and it was a crazy concept and he was
using it to close the audience but I
like the most expensive thing that all
of us are paying for is the information
that we don't know
and that's like both frightening and
also incredibly exciting because like
fish in the best ponds right like a good
fisherman knows where to fish and
everybody can put a hook and uh and a
thing and stick it over the water but
like the best fisherman know where and
when Etc and that's exactly the story
that you said is like I had the hook and
I had the The Reel and all that stuff
but like I went to where the best where
the best fishing was and like to me that
skill same work yeah same amount of time
same Rod or zeros
one of the things in the first book is
like
you want to like sell better customers
so if you want to sell better customers
yeah like this it's the exact same thing
you just said which is like if I were to
do cro work so conversion rate
optimization for a website that's
e-commerce and I work for a store that's
doing a million dollars a year and I say
cool I'm able to increase your
conversion air set by 20 Okay cool so
now that's doing 1.2 million dollars a
year I made 200 000 in value and maybe I
can get 10 of that I get 20 grand okay
cool I do the same work to a business
doing 100 million dollars a year I make
them 20 million dollars for my 20 bump
and I get 10 that and I make two million
dollars
twenty thousand two million a hundred X
same work to your point and to me that's
skill
like to know that simple simple fact
like I had this tweet that went super
viral which was uh solve rich people
problems they pay better
a lot of controversy around that
um but it's true and so
find the people and a different way of
saying it is find the people who value
what you have the most
and I'm sure you've heard this have you
heard the story of the the father and
the son with the car no okay
so maybe I have fun okay no it's good
it's good so there's there's a father
who gifts his son an old beat up car
and he says you know hey I don't know if
it drives or not but you can take it
down to the um
the dealership down the street see if
you can trade and get some money he's
like okay so he goes down the street
goes to the dealership they say
we'll give you a thousand bucks for it
and he come you know hears him out comes
back home he's like Dad they said give
me a thousand bucks he's like okay he's
like go to the impound yard where they
you know break the cars up just for
Metal He's like see what they'll give
you goes there and uh the guy's like ah
I don't know this might be 500 bucks of
metal a kid like you know comes back
home he's like Daddy you know he said it
was gonna be 500. he's like okay he's
like hey go down the street to that uh
that antique uh dealership see if
they've got anything that use car lot
and it's like okay so he goes down there
talks to the guy
comes back home super excited he's like
Daddy won't believe it he's like this is
a historic car there's only like 10 of
them left he's like it's worth a hundred
thousand dollars
and so the father smiles and he's like
and the less that I want you to know is
that it's not necessarily who you are
but the people that value you the most
and so you can talk to different people
and go to the people who value you and I
just I love that story because from a
it's a huge it's a huge business story
in terms of like cell sell where the
fish are where the big fish are like if
you if you're gonna go Hook Fish go to
go where the whales are
um it takes the same work but a lot of
it's just belief people don't think it's
possible and so a lot of times you have
to just keep leveling up and you sell
your first ten thousand dollar thing you
sell your first hundred thousand dollar
thing sell your first multi-million
dollar package you realize that's the
exact same thing it's just so maybe if
I'm list if anybody's listening right
now it is the same thing it's the exact
same thing and sometimes it's easier
like you know you've seen that Meme that
says like uh so what exactly am I going
to be getting for this 50 thing right
and then it's like uh fifty thousand
dollar clients like wire set yesterday
like what else do you need like it's and
that's totally true
um but I think there's a skill in
understanding where to fish
certainly a skill
um information it's information it's
even knowing that there was another Lake
over there and and that's why like
listening to conversations like this is
so valuable for people because it lifts
a curtain and you go what the [__] you
guys were behind here the whole time
partying that's what my business life
has been like it's like a gradually like
I think I heard Kevin Hart describe on
Joe Rogan one time where he said there's
this other room yeah where these people
are playing this other set of money
games yeah and then when you get in that
room you get you're almost pissed off
that nobody told you this room existed
but then there's another door yeah
and then you get through there maybe a
couple of years later and you find these
other people these [__] billionaires
that are playing another set of games
and you're going what and they're
chilling yeah
they're just spoken to guys they're not
even doing any hard why can you go tell
me the games that you guys have been
playing in here yeah and then again the
frustration is and that's kind of what I
feel like in my business life it's been
like where I had the jump I'm charging I
don't know I remember my first we found
our first deck from 2014 charging I
remember the package we did gold silver
and bronze it was like you know 200
package for like support and then 500
and then the gold package it will be
through everything in for a thousand
dollars and I remember one of my first
clients um accepting that and then I
think today like the only difference
okay there's skills that have increased
but information is the big thing knowing
how to do it
you know
um
when you think about curtains that have
lifted that have really shifted the
games you play from a value money
perspective like where someone's Turned
the Lights On You [__] of course yeah is
there anything else that comes to mind
like big macro games yeah
um I think a big you know when I the big
I will answer it with the stair steps of
how each order of magnitude changing my
income so when I went from being an
employee to self-employed I went from
making four figures a month to five
figures a month and that was for me just
like I'm now in control the level above
that was I started having other people
who worked for me I'd even know that was
possible sounds crazy like I was like
you can hire people because my my
members in my gym were like you know
other people can work here I'm like
cleaning the floor and doing the
marketing and teaching class they're
like I was like didn't think about that
right and then went to six figures a
month right and then from there stayed
there did the turnaround business still
had the same organizational structure
had another degree of Leverage and so
the next review of Leverage was that I
started licensing so it's digital right
so the cost for you know cost of goods
was basically nothing and then that's
when things started skyrocketing that
got me to seven figures a month and then
eight figures a month was using leverage
through capital
which is where you know we're at now and
I would imagine that nine figures a
month will probably be some level of
technology or more uh media on my side
but all of these things are about
leverage and so this is like one of my
favorite topics in the whole world but
if we Define leverages the difference
between what you put in and what you get
out so if you have a lot of Leverage but
a little bit in you get a lot out if you
have no leverage or low leverage you put
a lot in you get a little bit out and a
lot of times people who are listening to
this and are not making as much money as
they want they're putting lots of input
in and not getting a lot out they have
low leverage opportunities and so
understanding how to get more for what
you put in is the game
overall and so the first level that I
described was Labor it's just work first
I was working for someone else then I
worked for myself and I got other people
to work for me the first level in each
of those levels was more leverage above
that I had media which is the thing that
I was licensing out so another degree of
Leverage I made it once and I could
license that out Infinity on top of that
I have capital I can take capital I
don't have to sacrifice time in order to
get something for it so it's high input
output
um above that would be some sort of
Technology you build the code once in
theory obviously you continue to improve
the code but theoretically you build a
thing once and then a million people can
use it and so you want to Stack as many
types of Leverage as you can and as much
of them as you can because like Joe
Rogan also has a show and somebody else
has a podcast they both technically are
using media as their as their as their
vehicle for leverage but he has
significantly more of it so it's not
just like I'm gonna use all these right
yes but it's also how much into what
degree but like Facebook had other
people's money he used media had other
people's work Max leverage Amazon same
thing right they used every element of
Leverage and they maxed all of them out
and um that's that's at least the the
curtain that and Naval talks about this
if you're familiar with Naval ravacon
um he talks about these things as the as
the the P the elements of Leverage are
four types of Leverage
um and understanding that for me has
kind of been a blueprint for wealth
overall and then you know Capital
there's degrees of capital right like
you first you can get friends and family
to give you money then you can get you
know institutional money and then you
can get public money right which you
know you saw like the IPO money like the
fact that the NASDAQ was Forex uh the
Dusseldorf exchange is that where it was
right
um there's just significantly more
capital in that market and so it same
work more zeros
um and so
I love this topic because I think that
that's fundamentally like the people who
move faster in life don't actually move
faster they get more for every step
are you happy I'm stoked Max stoke
you know I'm not asked this question for
for a long time but yeah I thought I'd
ask it because it's kind of similar to
what we've um been talking about today
but if um
if happiness was like a list of
ingredients
and it was a recipe is there anything
missing from your recipe that would make
you even more happy
and sometimes that recipe is about
balancing the ingredients you need two
eggs and 100 eggs yeah one cup of flour
yeah
um for me it's always been about
autonomy
I should be able I want to I want to be
able to do what I find interesting
um and that's that's been the core of it
and what I do will change
but the core of having the freedom to do
it has been the center of it and so for
me I don't think my freedom has I mean
not in recent history my freedom hasn't
fundamentally changed in any way and so
I would say that I'm the same level of
contentedness as I was last year
um but I find engagement
in what I do and that that's that's
I'll give you my definition of Happiness
which is doing what you like to do with
people you like
and doing that as much as you possibly
can
and that's my simple definition
interesting
I've tried to I've tried to figure that
out that like professional like I guess
it's not even a professional thing but
I've tried to figure out and summarize
that's a wonderful summary the the place
I've gotten to is if you're surrounded
by people you love you're doing
something that challenges you which I
think is an interesting one you've kind
of encapsulated it just by saying things
you like but yeah the challenges you
gives you a sense of forward motion and
progress
um towards a meaningful goal and that's
a subjective thing could be raising a
kid or making a million dollars whatever
I think that's kind of what I call it my
echo guy if I find if I'm in that state
and it's a state
um I think I'm happy
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest ah
without knowing who they're going to be
asking it to
I'm terrified why does everyone get so
scared when I do this like aren't my
question scary like
everyone someone's gonna like try to
stick the note like okay I'm gonna think
of it
what's gonna get we have these um
conversation cards where we've taken all
the questions written in this book and
we've made them into cards so people can
play at home
um I'm actually going to slide them over
to you and just ask you to pick one
conversation card okay
um I've picked a couple there that I
think are Stitch UPS so
let me go from The Middle okay
and the question is what are the
failures you cherish the most
I'm gonna give two
I am very grateful that I hated the job
that I had
because I think that I am the type of
person because of how hard it was for me
to quit that if I had liked a job enough
I don't think I would have left
and I think I would have gone to the
business school and done the next thing
like if I had a job worked for people
whatever it was that I enjoyed enough
just enough
I might not be where I am now and I
think that I cherish the fact that it
was so miserable that it got me to
change
like that that that job changed my life
from a
like Soul perspective
um going through what I did with Layla I
cherish those times because
a lot of people live worst case scenario
years into their marriage years into
their relationship and then they kind of
like see what the other person is made
of
I got to do that before I married the
person and so there haven't been any
surprises since then and it's something
that's like shared misery to a certain
degree but like spiritual strength or
spiritual whatever you want to call it
um
I know she's got my back and there's an
element to that story that I didn't tell
but when we really needed money at one
point I flew Leila out to do this launch
I couldn't go with her
and I actually
broke up with her but I was like I can't
do this right now
and so for 28 days we were not together
and most girls people would probably
been like screw this guy
um but instead Layla set the all-time
record for a launch that still hasn't
been broken
and
when she came back I was like
she stood tall when everything in my
life was crumbling around me and she
like made it happen and I knew that
wherever I wanted to go I needed someone
like that with me and so I cherish the
failures that of that entire season
because there were many
um because I wouldn't know what I have
today if I hadn't been through those
tests with her then
man that's beautiful in the Diary of a
CEO we have hundreds of questions that
have been left by our guests and we've
put them on these cards
and on these cards you have the question
that's been left in the diver CEO the
name of the person who wrote the
question and if you turn it over there's
a QR code if you scan that code you can
see which guests answered the question
and watch the video of them answering it
every time I've done this podcast and
every time we've asked the kind of
questions we ask here I feel a
tremendous sense of affinity to the
guest and our aim with these cards is
that you can create that sense of
connection through vulnerability at home
with the people you love the most and I
have some good news for you as of today
you can add your name to the waiting
list to be the first in line to get your
own set of conversation cards at the
conversationcards.com
we have a another question which is the
question that people leave in the book I
thought I just nailed it I thought that
was it I think this is the new tradition
I'm talking about the old tradition one
last question Alex but you did nail that
so I'll be honest you stuck that Landing
um when do you feel the most emotionally
connected to yourself
literally my like heartbeat thought was
when I'm working
like the first Harpy thought and then
like if I had to be really specific when
I'm in the throes of writing
I had a a writing scholarship coming out
of high school I was the vice editor of
the newspaper I was the editor-in-chief
of the literary magazine when I was in
high school I've enjoyed writing
um it's one of those things that for me
like
you said like challenge like writing is
a thing is a monster that only gets
stronger and stronger and you get better
and better at writing and you see the
flaws in your writing the better you get
at writing and so it always feels like
it matches the difficulty matches my
ability at all times and so it is the
thing
that I experienced the greatest degree
of flow in the most regularly
makes a lot of sense once there's a lot
of questions that we've talked about
earlier on as well
Alex thank you so much for your time
um and being here it's been an
incredibly diverse and enlightening and
honest and vulnerable and inspiring and
soul filling conversation in so many
respects and um I I know for sure you're
just at the very start of your journey I
asked you about the staircase I know
that you've just got one foot on the
first step and I think it's going to be
incredible to watch um the next couple
of seasons of your life because you're
destined for incredible things there's
absolutely no doubt in that so thank you
Alex appreciate your time I appreciate
that thank you it's kind words
I've now been a cool Drinker for about
four years roughly so much so that I
ended up investing in the company
um and I play a role on the board of the
company but they also very kindly
sponsored this podcast and to be honest
I've never said this before but he all
believed in this podcast before anybody
else the CEO Julian
um told me before we even launched the
podcast how successful it would be and
that heel would back it and I absolutely
have a huge amount of gratitude for them
for that support but an even greater
sense of gratitude for the fact that
they've helped me stay nutritionally
complete throughout the chaos and
hecticness of my tremendously busy
business schedule so if you haven't
tried out here which I hope most of you
have at least given it a go by now try
it out it's an unbelievable way to try
and stay nutritionally on course if you
have a hectic busy schedule and let me
know what you think send me a tweet and
a DM tag me let me know what you think
quick one as you guys know we're lucky
enough to have blue jeans as a sponsor
and supporter of this podcast for anyone
that doesn't know blue jeans is an
online video conferencing tool that
allows you to have slick fast good
quality online meetings without any of
those glitches that you'd normally find
with other meeting online providers you
know the ones I'm talking about and they
have a new feature called Blue Jeans
basic which I wanted to tell you about
blue jeans basic is essentially a free
version of their top quality video
conferencing and that means that you get
immersive video experiences you get that
super high quality super easy and zero
fuss experience and apart from zero time
limits on meetings and calls it also
comes with High Fidelity audio and video
including Dolby voice they also have
expertise grade security so you can
collaborate with confidence it's so
smooth that it's quite literally changed
the game for myself and my team without
compromising quality at all so if you'd
like to check them out search
bluejeans.com and let me know how you
get on DM me tweet me whatever works for
you let me know how you find it
[Music]
oh